I created an account on Tick Tock and  I'm going to tell you openly here the  only reason I did is to give the things  I believe in on the people on Tick Tock  that are not being heard so I was  talking and you know China I was talking  capitals anything that they don't  support I was talking about it  and then gradually uh you saw what  messages they didn't like we did one  video on China prior to that I did the  numbers the other day with Kai the prior  100 videos I think some 10 of them got a  million views five of them got five  million views but should have got a  hundred thousand views prior hundred the  moment I clicked put a video about China  after that 400 videos on Tick Tock only  one of them got over a hundred thousand  views zero over 50 000 views 400 videos  of those 400 on Instagram they all  performed okay we're still posting stuff  because we want them to be held  accountable on what they're doing but  this company is one president away from  being banned in America